okay hello everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q
a for kids and others
so i seem to always not get finished
with all the questions that come in a
particular week so there's always a
supply of them
to start off with and today is no
exception
so let's see first question i have here
is from a dharma
asking about my thoughts about claude
shannon information theory
information entropy and so on
and uh commenting on what do i think
about
significance and the story of it
uh i never unfortunately i never met
claude shannon uh claude shannon
uh was um uh
did his most well-known work
in information theory in the 1940s and
early 1950s
and actually although he lived uh he
worked at mit
and um lived quite close to where i live
um uh he had sort of become something of
a recluse
um by the by even by the 1960s and had a
lot of
a lot of exotic hobbies and a lot of um
wonderful uh pieces of kind of hacky
development of computer-like things
whether it was
computers to beat roulette where you
would measure off the um
uh the timing of roulette wheel by by
clicking something in your shoe or all
kinds of other
schemes or schemes for beating the stock
market and and all kinds of other things
like that
but his best known work was some
work on information theory what is the
idea of information theory
um the question is in a sense
if you have a message how much
true information is there in that
message
how much is is there a way to measure
this sort of information content of a
message the message has something to say
it might tell you that uh you know
your um i don't know your your
you know pet dog has just won a dog
competition or whatever it is
um it um uh but but
if you just ignore the the um uh
the real the the sort of the the um
the meaning of the message you just say
how much information content is there in
this message
well today we're pretty familiar with
one measure of that it's like how
big is the file that contains the text
that is that message
and in that file in a first
approximation
every um every character of the message
takes up one bite uh that's
not quite completely true because it's
true in english
where we have only uh 26 letters in our
alphabet
but if you go to an idiographic language
like chinese or something
japanese you'll have you know 30 to 50
000 different signs that each represent
a word or a piece of a word and so
they're not they're not quite
it's not the case that you can specify
every one of those
in just a single byte and and typically
those are specified using this unicode
standard these days in which those
languages
fit into two bytes each each character
each sign in those languages fits into
two bytes
so what is a byte a byte is
eight bits of information each bit is a
one or a zero
and so in eight bits if you have them
all independently chosen one or zero
there are 256 possible configurations of
that from zero zero zero zero zero eight
times to one one
one eight times um the total number of
different possibilities is 256.
so you get to encode 256 different
possible characters in that one byte
when you have two bytes you get the
square of that number
so you get to encode 65 536
different possible characters and most
of the current glyphs of the world fit
in that uh
in that number of um um
possible characters uh there's been a
big sort of
escape of characters which is an emoji
um
people generate all kinds of emoji and
they as you generate thousands and
thousands of emoji
you no longer have them be able to fit
in the 665 000
uh possible sort of uh slots there and
so there are now
additional like four byte versions of
unicode which allow
up to four billion characters which
should be enough emoji to
supply the world for a long time and
also some of the more
uh obscure and um
and ancient languages like babylonian
cuneiform or something like this
those fit in beyond the
so-called plain zero unicode in any case
so basically you have a message and the
most obvious way that you can
send the message is to let's say put it
in a file
or you could take your file you could
send it by email you could send it
through
a text message or something like this
but basically
every character in the file is if it's
in english
represented by one byte um of of data
uh which corresponds to eight bits which
is 256 possibilities
and there's sort of a convention that
the characters in english
get represented by particular numerical
codes numerical bit patterns in this
bite
it's the ascii uh convention
from the 1950s i guess um
and uh um i always forget this i think
uh capital a is i think 65 for whatever
reason
um the um and capital b is 66 if i'm
right about the 65 and so on just
follows through the alphabet
but each each basically each letter of
the alphabet is assigned
in application lower cases assigned a
particular numerical code
and that's what uh and how that's how
the individual letters in the message
represented
okay so in a first approximation if i
make a message and that message
is a thousand characters long thousand
letters and spaces and so on long
then i'm going to use a thousand bytes
to transmit that message
okay here's a key observation you're
sort of wasting effort
to send every letter separately here's
why
let's say you have a letter q in english
then
with overwhelming probability that will
be followed by a letter u
so you don't really need to if you if
you have the right sort of thing you
most times you send a queue you don't
need to bother to send that you after it
and in general there are lots of these
kind of
pieces of sort of redundancy in english
places where you can kind of predict
what's going to happen
based on what you've already seen and at
least with a good chance you can predict
what's going to happen
okay so how do you use that well the
most basic thing
is that in english different letters
occur with different frequencies in a
typical piece of english text so
e is the most common t is next most
common
not sure what's most common after that
but it goes on and then
on the least common end of things like z
and y and x
and v and so on and so
okay so given that what is the best way
to send a message given you're going to
be sending a lot more ease
than z's what does that mean about how
you send a message
well this was already thought about back
in the 1800s and 1830s i think
um when samuel morse um was using
telegraphs
to send messages and what is a telegraph
for
people in the younger end here um
before my time actually too but um
before there were telephones
so you know telephones allow you to turn
your voice into an electrical signal
transmit it to wherever it's being
transmitted to
and get back voice at the other end
before that was possible
you could at least send little bips by
uh you threw electrical wires and so you
would have this
this um this device where you just have
a little key
and you keep press the key and every
time you press the key
it makes an electrical connection and
that causes
it to that causes the uh voltage to be
a little piece of of current to be sent
down this wire
and you could send it and people laid
telegraph wires
all over the all over the country all
over the world
as a way to to communicate information
and so on
on a telegraph how would you send a
message well
what you would do is you would have uh
two kinds of um
two kinds of things you could make a dot
or a dash a dot would be a short
bip and a dash would be a longer visit
um depending on how long you held down
this telegraph key
so so you're turning whatever message
you're going to produce
into a bunch of dot dot dots dash dash
dot dash dot
et cetera et cetera et cetera and um the
uh
um uh uh that that's
um so that was kind of the the approach
to sending messages
um and then the question was what was
the best way given that you were going
to be sending a particular piece of text
that way
what was the best way to encode it so
that you had to
put in the least effort clicking on your
on your telegraph key
so what samuel morse realized is that if
e is a shorter code
than z then on average the amount of
effort you have to go through to send a
message
is going to be less so he made e be a
dot t be a dash
and i have to say i'm sorry to say i
don't know most code i know a few other
letters
like s is dot dot dot o is dash dash
dash
um i know that because the famous of
distress signal sos
is dot dot dash dash dash dot dot dot
um and uh so
but in any case with samuel morse's
scheme the
you took a piece of text the e's were
short
the z's were much more uh to send and
if if every letter had been an equal
length to send then you've got a
thousand characters
let's say each letter was represented by
four different
uh sort of elements in this telegraph
thing then you would have four
thousand times you have to press the key
on the other hand
if you use most code then
you have much less than four thousand um
sort of uh key presses because
you know you've got lots of ease which
are just one one element
and the z's might be five elements but
they're much rarer
okay so this idea of make the common
stuff be
coded with something shorter is a
general way to make
what you have to send in a message
shorter so what claude shannon
got to thinking about was what's a
general way of thinking about how short
can you make a message
what's a general way of understanding uh
how does this morse code thing which we
have one particular example of there
what's a general way of what's the best
so what's the what's the sort of
approach to making moss code
that will work for um uh for everything
and what he realized was uh that there's
a sort of way to think about that
mathematically
that actually it's very similar to the
way one thinks about uh
questions about in physics about
thermodynamics about the question of if
you have this gas
it has all these molecules bouncing
around in certain ways but you only need
to know
uh some you only know some features of
it how many different
underlying configurations of the gas can
there be anyway the mathematics of that
question
turns out to be the same as the
mathematics of the question that claude
shannon was interested in asking
and the big result is uh p log p
so the the idea is for every
okay so here's a way to think about it
and this this is a little bit mathy
um but uh but bear with me for a second
so let's say we've got
um a bunch of binary bits ones or zeros
that we're going to use to represent
something
let's say we have four possibilities
that we're trying to represent
well then we need two bits to do that
because
with the two bits we can have zero zero
zero one one zero one one that's four
possibilities
so if we're trying to represent four
possibilities we can do that by just
using two bets
okay we're trying to represent let's say
we're trying to represent seven
possibilities
how many bits do we need well two isn't
going to be enough
uh three bits we can deal with eight
possibilities
um that's two times two times two two
cubed
or eight possibilities and in general if
we have
n bits we can deal with uh each bit
doubles the number of possibilities we
can deal with so it's 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 n times or 2 to the n
and so that means for example if we have
8 bits that's 2 to the 8
and 2 to the 8 is 256 and that's the
thing i already mentioned
is the number of possible configurations
the number of possible
possibilities that can be represented by
one byte
okay so what shannon noticed is if you
have
uh all these different possibilities
then
you can if you have um let's say you
have
um i don't know s possibilities
then the number of um what you need to
know is what power of two
gives you uh uh is
is um gives you s basically and that's
the logarithm to the base two of s
that's the mathematical representation
of that um
and so then then the question is if you
were looking at all these different
possibilities and each of them occurred
with equal frequency
so let's say there were eight
possibilities and each of them occurred
one-eighth of the time
okay then uh what you could do is you
say
uh you just say what are the
probabilities with which these different
things occur
okay there are eight possibilities each
one eighth of the time
the log of that probability that log of
that one-eighth
is massively minus the log of eight
or otherwise known as uh log to the base
two of eight
is three so that would be minus three so
in other words the
if you look at the probability if
everything was equally probable
then the probabilities would be one over
the number of possibilities
and the log of that is basically minus
um the uh the the uh the the exponent
of the of the number of possibilities so
it kind of works out the same way
okay now the question is if different
ones of these
if different things that you might
transmit different symbols you might
transmit
occur a different frequency how do those
contribute
to the uh the total number of
of of um of of elements
you on average need to send so in the
most code case because e
is the most common um it has it has a
high probability
uh z is less probable but you you code
them
you you can send them different lengths
anyway the end result is
that the thing that tells you what the
expected length what the best possible
length
that you could achieve by
by encoding all these characters in the
optimal way
is this uh sum of p log p for each
probability p
of the different possible symbols and
the way that works is first thing you do
is you say okay you know e is the most
common z is the least common
that's looking at single letter
frequencies then you can go on a look at
diagrams two letter pairs
for example th is pretty common uh you
know zq
is extremely uncommon probably
you know if you looked on the web the
number of places zq occurs and the whole
many terabytes of data on the web
of textual data on the web is really low
so
so you know th is really common you
should encode that with something really
short zq
is really short really uncommon so you
can encode that with something
incredibly long it's not going to matter
the length of the message so the
question then is what is the
uh what what is the amount of of
reduction you can get if you if you
coded things in the best possible way if
you found the best possible way to
represent th with a short thing
it's eq with a long thing and so on how
short can you make a message in english
okay so shannon's formula basically
tells one the answer to that
and it tells one that for english the
answer is about half
so in other words about half the letters
in a typical piece of english are
somehow redundant and you can kind of
test that for yourself if you just take
take a piece of english text and you
just start blacking out some letters
and you ask yourself can you still tell
what the english text said
the answer will be up until you end up
with a bit more than half
the letters blacked out you can you can
very accurately say hey i know what that
said
okay so so then the question is given
that we know
so so what shannon's information theory
idea was
um was to work out given knowing the
frequencies of letters and blocks of
letters and so on
what is the shortest amount of shortest
length that you can
can encode that shortest thing you can
encode that with
so two issues one issue is can you
actually find a way to do that in coding
that's one issue the other issue is the
encoding we're talking about is an
encoding
that doesn't know anything about what
the text means
well let's take these two things in turn
so one question is can you find
the actual shortest encoding can you
find a procedure
and there are various procedures that
are used so one common procedure is
called huffman coding
and um it kind of uses a it just sort of
has a tree of possibilities and it's
kind of always filling in another branch
on the tree for something it hasn't seen
before
and the ones that seen a lot end up
being sort of branches at the top of the
tree that
need less less tree branches to get to
so to speak that's one common method
another method called lcw encoding or
dictionary encoding
and that's used in for example programs
like zip uh or
gzip or whatever and the the um
compression programs on the web
dictionary encoding works like this
dictionary encoding says
uh it kind of is making continually
making a dictionary so it says
did i see th before okay yes let's let's
let's give that a a name in our
dictionary did i see th e before
yes let me give that a name in my
dictionary did i see
elephant you know the letters for
elephant before yes
let's give that a name in the dictionary
and it arranges it
so that things that have been seen
before basically things that are seen
often end up being coded as short things
in the dictionary
whole whole blocks of text that have
been seen before
the more times they're seen the more
they'll be encoded in the dictionary
and the shorter they'll be encoded in
the dictionary and so that that kind of
method
for something like english text does
achieve something close to 50
compression by using this kind of uh you
know
thing where you're making up code words
based on dictionary
another another common very simple
method of encoding
that is more relevant for oh i don't
know let's say you take a
you take an image of your screen okay
the image of the screen a lot of the
image a lot of the screen a lot of your
screen is really boring
it's uh it's just white for example just
you know in some window it's just pixel
pixel pixel pixel pixel they all got the
same color
so there's a method of encoding called
run length encoding that deals with that
and what run length encoding does is it
says
if you've got many identical copies of
the same thing the way you can
encode that is to just say it's a
hundred
white pixels so instead of giving white
pixel white pixel white pixel 100 times
you're just saying it's a hundred times
white pixel
so that's run length encoding when
you're dealing with images and sounds
and so on
there are different methods of encoding
uh that basically use the fact that our
human visual system or auditory system
doesn't recognize some imperfections so
you can you can have
sometimes you can just have encoding
like i'm talking about for text
where you don't destroy any of any
aspect of the message it's lossless
encoding
you're just kind of using mathematical
properties to use shorter code words
for one thing than another and so on but
you can also go further than that
and you can say i really don't need to
hear every wiggle in the audio
uh trace or i really don't need to see
every precise pixel in the image
all that i need to see is things that i
as a human will recognize
and so for example in the case of of uh
audio
things that are really high frequency
wiggles can be kind of cut out because
humans are not going to
hear them and maybe even the loudspeaker
on your computer isn't going to play
them
um so there are methods like that but
any case when it comes to just
lossless encoding encoding where you're
going to be able to precisely get the
message back again
there's been sort of a long running
story of can one actually
achieve the the level of compression
that shannon's uh results
say one should be able to achieve and
there are now codes that do
a really good job i think there are now
some codes that are that have provably
achieved that
for lots of different cases and and
that's been a a big story for example in
the in the 5g
telephony world there's been for for
whatever reason a big push to get
the absolute optimal codes it doesn't
really matter that much anymore because
because even even codes that aren't
perfectly perfect
still do really really pretty good job
at compressing typical signals
okay so anyway that's that's compression
just based on looking at
essentially the statistics of how often
letters occur blocks of letters occur
things like that
there's another thing to think about
which is well maybe the message actually
means something
so let's say you were given the digits
of pi 3.1415926 etc etc etcetera
you might say to encode a million digits
of pi
that's going to take me a lot of effort
because the digits of pi kind of random
and i'm going to have to just code each
digit with something that represents
each of the 10 possibilities etc that's
a million things
but actually in a sense you might say
that's really silly
because all i have to do is tell you
it's a million-digit supply and that is
a very
short thing to say in a short thing to
transmit and so long as my receiver
understands that it has to essentially
run the program of recompute
the million digits of pi i've got a much
shorter way to send the message
so this leads us to an idea of what's
called algorithmic information theory
um where where one's asking not what can
one compress
just both fixed codes fixed encoding
that doesn't know what the message means
but how do you make a program that
will produce the thing you were going to
say so in the case of pi it would be
that short program just compute
the digits and so on well so that that's
sort of the best way to do
encoding is to say just tell me how to
make the thing
just tell me how to reconstruct the
thing at the other end and actually
even in audio encoding there's a certain
amount of that that's done in mp
mp3 mp4 and so on it's uh it's got all
kinds of wild um
actually that that's some uh
yeah that's a that's well there are
there are
audio encoding methods that are used for
phones and so on
where essentially what you're doing is
you're you're modeling
the human vocal tract and you're
basically making a program that
specifies parameters of how the vocal
tract will move
and you're recognizing oh this is how
the vocal tract of the
person who said this moved and let's
let's essentially simulate that when the
when the
when the message is received let's only
send the sort of
the motion parameters for the vocal
tract and then the other one will
reconstruct the actual sound that would
have come out of a
vocal tract that's moving that way so
this idea that
you know you basically send the program
instead of sending
the raw data that's kind of this the
sort of ultimate form of compression
so you might ask okay so you know claude
shannon had this method of figuring out
what the best compression is
when you're just sort of given
statistical information about the
message what's the best
compression that you can get when when
you're
asking for the shortest program that
reproduces the message
that was something that was thought
about a lot by a good friend of mine
named greg traiton
actually he did it when he was a high
school student in new york city back in
the 1960s
he figured out this idea of so-called
algorithmic information theory
where you say the amount of information
contained in a message
is the shortest program that will
reproduce that message
so it's a cool idea the question is can
you actually work out what that what the
length of that shortest program is
and the answer is no it is impo in
general is impossibly hard to do that
in a sense what you're asking is and
part of the reason is
let's say you say i want the shortest
program okay well maybe there's an
incredibly short program
but it takes a billion steps to run to
produce the message
if you just got start testing programs
and say is this program going to work is
this program going to work
well some of those programs might take
an arbitrarily long time to run
even though they would successfully
produce your message so in fact we know
from sort of general theory about
computers that
in general there's no there's no you
can't in a finite amount of time
guaranteed to have found the shortest
program
that will reproduce your particular
message so although algorithmic
information content
is in principle a really good thing to
look at in practice
unless you say well i'm only going to
consider computations that take such and
such amount of time
you'll never know what the truly
shortest program actually is
now this question about finding shortest
programs is closely related to a lot of
things about making models of things so
for example
let's say i'm trying to uh reproduce
i don't know um uh
oh what's a good example i don't know
some a tree for example
and i'm trying to make a model of a tree
where i get all the leaves and i'm
figuring out how that's all gonna work
and
and i know how the tree is going to
behave and so on and so different cases
what i want essentially is to have a
program
that reproduces the behavior of the tree
i want to take the actual tree or my
you know a thousand trees that i've
studied and i want to say
give me a program that will reproduce
aspects of those trees that i care about
and so the problem of making models of
things is the same as this problem
in a sense of finding shortest programs
that represent messages
in the case of modeling the messages
whatever experimental data you picked up
and
the program is the sort of the model
that specifies how you could reproduce
that data
um theoretically so to speak and so then
then there's a whole
kind of question of you can do things
like you can say well
i've got all this data and i'm going to
make a model and it's going to reproduce
the data perfectly
okay small bug the model is really
complicated in fact the model is so
complicated
that it's basically amounts to just
writing down the data and saying
okay run this program and get the data
well you put the data into the programs
it's not surprising it will get it
so there's this sort of trade-off which
comes between how accurate do you want
the model to be
versus how big do you want the model to
be so
the model can be perfectly accurate by
just having every bit of the data
right there in the model or the model
could be really tiny
and get the uh and be very and
be one percent off in getting in
reproducing the data
so there's this kind of trade-off
between model size
and accuracy of of um of reproducing the
data that one has to consider and that's
a
that's a big issue in a lot of both um
sort of
the sort of philosophical thinking about
modeling and in practice and things like
machine learning
um whether whether you really managed to
make a true
sort of extraction of the essence of the
data whether you've basically got
a neural net or something like that it
just has a copy of the data inside it
so anyway that's a it's kind of a long
answer to questions about
information theory i think that the um
uh the role of of information theory as
a way to understand sort of compression
and things like
that is something that's baked deep into
our
kind of way of doing things we do with
data and computing
i think that these ideas about sort of
the algorithmic
character of information is sort of
poorly captured and people sometimes
imagine
that there's kind of a magic to
information theory that says yes
it's the true information content of a
message what we get from you know
shannon's formula and so on
it's not in the case of pi for example
it would give you completely the wrong
answer
for most practical cases it's not
accounting for the fact that
the message actually came from somewhere
there was a thing that produced it
somehow
and if you can model that thing if you
can represent if you can have a program
that represents what that thing does
you can potentially say much more simply
uh you can you can have a much shorter
description
of what goes on now i have to say that
in my own
uh efforts in science one of the things
that i've discovered
is that even things that have very small
programs can be very complicated
people might you might imagine that if
you have a small program that you could
only get
some behavior that would be quite simple
you get this little program you run it
and just
you know go one zero one zero one zero
repeating all the time
but actually what we know from
stuff basically i worked on in the 1980s
and beyond
is that that isn't true that even with
very tiny programs
even with programs you kind of just pick
at random and small programs
you can end up with these immensely
complicated uh
behavior and i think that's a that's a
very important phenomenon
it's a phenomenon that's probably the
reason why in nature
we see so many things that look to us
complicated it's the same kind of idea
make sure it's just picking a simple
program at random and producing things
that look complicated and
where the shannon information content so
to speak will be very large
even though the algorithmic information
content in fact is
is just this tiny program so so it's a
little bit misleading sometimes
and people sometimes kind of imagine
that because there's this kind of
mathematical theory of information
that it's kind of the whole story of
what is the true
content the true information content of
a thing that's not really right
it's better to think about that in terms
of how would you make the thing from a
program and so on
all right
oh boy lots and lots of questions here
oh my
um
it's a question from adam here what
books and exercises are best to take
from a high school level physics
mathematics understanding
to be able to make sense of the wolfram
physics project
uh model um i guess i would
pitch my own um my own writings on
wolframpphysics.org i tried to write
kind of an
introduction um both both a kind of a
quick introduction and a 400 page
introduction that i think goes sort of
step by step i recommend looking that
i'd also recommend
there's a piece of software tools i
recommend looking at the tutorial there
which allows you to actually run all the
the code um and try for yourself
you know actually run the things and see
how it works
um okay there's a question from jack
bound here why is the core of the earth
as hot as the surface of the sun is it
fusion or fission is this true of many
planets and moons in our solar system
okay uh astrophysics type question
all right so first question is it's a
it's kind of a surprising fact that the
earth is hot inside
how do we even know that the earth is
hot inside well you know volcanoes are
kind of a clue
but uh people you know when you when you
drill a hole
deep into the earth the deeper you go
the hotter it gets
there's a um we also know that um
the earth is liquid inside and the
reason we know the earth is liquid
inside is because when an earthquake
happens
it produces a big you know it wobbles
the earth
and by looking at essentially the the
waves that are generated by
you know an earthquake happens it
wobbles the earth
that that produces waves that propagate
through the earth
and by looking at those at the uh how
those waves propagate through the earth
we can tell what's inside the earth
actually there are there are two kinds
of earthquake waves
there are ones that go along the surface
where the where the
well basically the surface of the earth
is wiggling up and down and there are
ones that go through the interior of the
earth
where you're getting compression
expansion compression expansion like a
sound wave
except that it's going through rock and
those waves occur
arrive at different speeds uh typically
the ones that are
really kind of the bad news for you know
a building or something like that are
the ones the shear waves
the ones on the surface that make things
go up and down a lot
but the ones that go through the
interior of the earth arrive more
quickly than those ones
so the
the way that we know that the airfest
molten core is that
we've we've been able to see those
seismic waves going through the earth
and we've been able to tell that they
have the characteristics of going
through a liquid rather than a solid
in fact we also know that right in the
very center of the earth there's a piece
of solid core
because there are some seismic waves if
we if we have an earthquake that happens
on one side of the earth
uh by the way i mean the earth is kind
of rigid enough
that an earthquake happening anywhere on
the earth produces
some vibrations anywhere else on the
earth and so if you have a seismometer
it's basically just a sort of a the
simplest form it's just sort of a
a carefully balanced weight that every
time sort of the earth
bounces up and down the weight doesn't
move and so
so it uh relative to the earth relative
to the sort of the
the casing of the seismometer the the
it's moving
and um and then you can get a trace on
it it used to be a pen trace nowadays
i'm sure they're all digital
um the um but any case the
a seismometer has um uh
um if you have a seismometer
anywhere on the earth you can detect any
basically
any real earthquake that happens
anywhere on the earth you can also
detect for example
any uh nuclear explosion anywhere on the
earth
quite easily with seismometers and
actually in modern times there's kind of
a cool
new method of doing seismometer dealing
with seismometers
which is if you use the fiber optic
cables that are used for communications
the um when you have a compression wave
going through the earth
the length of the fiber optic cable is
going to change slightly
and um and so the uh um
and um you can or rather the the
yeah the and and so by using kind of um
by using sort of the network of fiber
optic cables and using ones that aren't
just being used
for communication you can make a
potentially a very sensitive seismometer
and one that can actually detect uh sort
of motion
before before an ordinary seismometer
would detect motion and potentially
actually predict earthquakes and
things like that a little bit faster or
at least no one earthquake has happened
a little bit faster
in any case the um so okay the earth has
a molten core the very center of the
earth
is happens to be solid why does it why
does it get to be that way well
as you go deeper and deeper in the earth
there's uh
it's there's also higher and higher
pressure so when you have
something well let's say like like water
or anything else
um and uh you know you're you're trying
to make it
you've got ice it's it's uh you heat it
up it turns into liquid water and so on
but if you were to squash it
really hard with high pressure then it
won't
become molten um as it won't turn into
liquid as easily because you're pushing
the atoms together
so they're still stuck together in a
solid they can't wiggle they can't move
around freely like they do in liquid
so so when the pressure goes up things
tend to make solids even when the
temperature is higher
and that's what's happening at the
center of the earth among other things
that there
it's also there's also a segregation of
actual materials
but different reasons but let's not go
into that right now
but in any case so the earth is the
liquid core
why is the earth hot inside people
aren't they're two different effects
that make the earth hot inside
and they're probably of about equal
importance
one reason why the earth is hot inside
is because it started that way
when the earth was originally formed
four and a half billion years ago
the um uh it was formed by lots of
little pieces of rock and other things
all crashing together
and that process of of and that they
were pulled together by gravity
and so things were falling onto the
earth as it was forming
and as they fall they're converting all
that energy
into heat and so as the earth formed
the the inside of the earth the earth
will have been hot
and so then the question is in four and
a half billion years
does heat manage to get out of the earth
or does it stay sort of trapped inside
the earth and the answer is
the the rate at which heat is sort of
conducted through rock
is such that some of it still stays
inside the earth
i mean the fact is that if you you know
at the surface of the earth we have
every day every night
you know the temperature goes up and
down the air
temperature increases and decreases if
you if you drill a hole
down you don't have to go very deep in
the soil
before before the temperature is pretty
much constant throughout the year
maybe 50 degrees i found it fahrenheit i
think is a common temperature
um that is some kind of average
temperature
that you get to not very deep in the
ground so
so in four and a half billion years the
the
the heat of the inside of the earth
hasn't really been able to be released
it's still sort of trying to get sort of
transmitted through the rock
that is that is that makes up the earth
so that's one part of
where the heat of the earth comes from
the other part of where the heat of the
earth comes from is a completely
different effect
which is the decay of radioactive
elements so
when the earth was formed some of uh
it had all the different chemical
elements you know
all well uh all
90 or so different kinds of stable
elements mostly
because if an element was unstable if an
element is such that
something like plutonium let's say where
um it decays quickly so its nucleus just
self-destructs um
in it might decay in a millionth of a
second or it might decay
in a second or whatever but anything
that decays in a second
even if it was there at some point it's
long gone
in four and a half billion years it's
really gone seriously
gone if it's decay if it decays if half
of it is gone in a second
then in four and a half billion years
it's really gone okay so when the earth
was formed
some of the okay this is getting into a
different different issue which is where
the elements
um in the earth come from and uh the
very
hydrogen helium lithium beryllium all
these successive elements have
successively more
protons and neutrons in their nuclei
and when the universe was formed in the
big bang
when the when the expansion of the
universe started up
um 14 billion years ago the um
uh that process where the universe was
very very hot at the beginning
gradually cooled down in this very hot
early universe
some chemical elements easily get made
hydrogen is there about a quarter of the
universe is then helium
and then successive elements get made
with lower and lower probabilities as
you go down the list of elements
and a little bit of details about how
different nuclear reactions happen
cores different elements have different
abundances
but basically that process of kind of
jamming uh what's happening in that case
is you're jamming
um uh little you're jamming
atomic nuclei together and they're
fusing
and you can get elements up to iron that
way you can
you can by by basically just fusing
things together that's something where
when you come together
they stick and there you've got a
heavier element so up to about iron you
get that to get beyond iron you need
different processes
the most common process is a supernova
when a star explodes
when a star explodes you generate this
whole sequence of heavier elements
um because there are other processes
that can occur
and um that are sort of much more
violent than happened in the early
universe
and um at least at that stage of the
early universe and in fact all the heavy
elements that exist on the earth
come from things like supernovas so
anything like gold for example
has to have come it didn't get made at
the beginning of the universe it got
made in something like a supernova
so when supernovas happen and make those
heavier elements some of the elements
they make
are things like uranium-235
and the feature of that is that it does
decay
but it decays very slowly uh it takes
half of
if you have a sample of it about half of
it is decayed in like a billion years
okay so that means that when that
element
or isotope of the element got
incorporated into the early earth
it's there it's stable enough that it
managed to make it to actually
be transported from somewhere else and
it formed in the
you know as the star for as the sun
formed the earth formed
took you know hundreds of millions
billions of years for all that to happen
hundreds of millions of years more like
or even perhaps less than that to for
the formation process but
but any case the thing the thing was
able to be transported with whatever it
was made
to to where we are it's all good it's
and it eventually gets incorporated into
the earth but when it's in the earth
uh it's decaying and when that
uranium-235
decays the decay so the nucleus
is you know it's sitting there as a
nucleus and then kaboom
it it uh it breaks itself in two pieces
for example
and um those two pieces uh it releases
energy when it doesn't so those two
pieces kind of zoom off uh with quick
pretty high energy
and that energy is then turned into heat
and so part of the heat of the earth
is a consequence of the decay of
radioactive elements and i think the
current
belief is that about half of the heat of
the earth is due to the decay of
radioactive elements
and half is due to a remnant heat from
the formation of the earth
okay so how do these processes work for
different kinds of things well if you
have a very small
thing even the moon for example there
may have been enough time
that whatever heat there was when the
moon was formed
has already has has managed to escape
from the moon
and so it doesn't so so in other words
the moon has completely solidified in
fact we know that that's the case
that the moon does not have a liquid
core the moon is solid all the way
through
um as you get up to different planets i
think mars may have a tiny liquid coil
i'm not sure if that's
uh people have looked for mars quakes
i'm not sure if that's
the last i i remember i think it may
have a tiny one
um and um we don't know in all other
cases and something like jupiter is a
more complicated case because jupiter
is a much bigger planet and its core is
probably solid hydrogen
um and it's a slightly different story
but but any case so
so and you know something like one of
the small asteroids or something it
definitely doesn't have a liquid core
because in the time since it was formed
there's been more than enough time for
sort of the heat to get out from the
center
and the whole thing to solidify so um
uh let's see i think that the um
um yeah that's the story of of what um
uh so if we i don't know it's a good
question i should know the answer i
don't
how long in the history of the earth it
will be before the before the core of
the earth
has um has solidified i don't know the
answer to that i would i would guess
quite a long time
i would guess many times the um the the
the
the time the earth has already been
around um i mean the you know the liquid
core of the earth
is responsible for things like the
magnetic field of the earth
um and uh uh and that that moves around
as sort of currents
in the mantle of the earth the liquid
part of the earth uh move around
okay ah let's see
oh gosh so many questions this is um
um
all right we'll do a completely
different kind of questions a question
here from parmenides
what good and bad aspects are there to
being financially successful
how did my life change when i first
became a millionaire gosh i've never
thought of myself as that
i mean i'm yes you know i've i've run a
successful company for
a third of a century now so so um
uh although my i would say that that
uh my main objective is
to make interesting things and make
interesting things happen
and i see sort of financial success as
being something necessary
for to achieve that goal not a very
interesting goal in its own right
i mean in um uh gosh i think that the
main for me
and i you know i don't think different
people have completely different
motivations for things
for me the main uh sort of
objective of making money is to be able
to
do interesting things do projects that i
want to do
uh and and those kinds of things i mean
you know our
our physics project for example is not
particularly expensive but
but um uh you know it it involves some
people
and and resources and computers and all
that kind of thing
and that project is something which you
know
because of a certain degree of financial
success
i i don't have to think about how much
that project costs if i wanted to scale
it up and have you know hundreds and
hundreds of people working on it
be a different story but at the scale of
a few people and machines and so on
it's like yes we can do that um you know
it's it's not it's not difficult to do
that
i would say that the the main thing as
far as i'm concerned is
is what possible things you can do
that uh you know how to be able to do
the things you want to do how to turn
ideas you have
into real things sometimes using money
is useful in turning ideas into real
things sometimes
it's not really a question of money it's
a question of of figuring out more stuff
you can throw as much money as you want
at it it's not going to help
um you know i myself in my particular
life have kind of
uh tried to sort of make enough money to
do the things that i want to do
but um i have not been particularly
interested in the pure
goal of making money um and uh
you know that that's a um uh in a sense
there's a sort of a trade-off sometimes
between
you can do things which are to me less
intellectually interesting
but make more money and it's like why
would i do that
i'm interested in doing the things that
i find interesting so to speak and
and the pure act of making money is not
one that i happen to find terribly
interesting
um i think that you know i have to say
as a matter
of observing the world that money has
positive value
and money also has negative value and i
i see just
so many cases uh where uh one ends up
seeing kind of the
the um uh you know the negative value of
money not necessarily for a person
themselves but for people around them
for the organizations around them you
know you take a company
and you give it too much money uh all
sorts of terrible things happen you
would think
that fantastic the company has too much
money
you know well it turns out it starts
doing crazy things and it starts doing
things that ultimately
are very counterproductive and so on in
many cases um
so it's uh you know i i i often i'm
aware of this kind of negative value of
money thing which is which is
one reason that uh at least in my own
life
i've kind of uh you know tried to make
enough money to do the things that i
want to do
but not money that uh kind of i don't
know what to do with so to speak
and that's that's always a a you know a
challenge because sometimes i have many
friends who made lots of money
and sometimes you kind of you intend to
make a certain amount of money and you
overrun and you make a lot more
and then what are you going to do with
this money well you want to give it away
in some responsible fashion but that's a
lot of work
and and sometimes you know it's it's
it's as much work
to sort of spend money responsibly as it
is often to make money
and so i think that's a a um uh
you know it's a complicated thing i
think that you know the the really the
the the issue is when you want to do a
project
when you want to do something it's like
uh
are you held back by the fact that it's
going to cost too much money you don't
have that money
or is it something where you can say
sure i can do that now if i look at
myself
there are projects that sure i might be
interested in doing them
but they cost way too much money but i'm
not even sure that money is the real
issue i mean you know
maybe i'm interested in something to do
with making molecular scale
uh building things on molecular scales
making kind of uh
sort of making a whole engineering
technology on molecular scales i've been
interested in that
for a long time and i might say well
let's pour some money into that and you
know we'll build this giant lab and
we'll do all these things
but honestly that's not the problem the
problem is i don't know how to do it
it's not that we need to spend 100
million dollars to build the lab and
build all this stuff
it's we don't know how to do it and yes
we could get a bunch of people to start
researching how to do it
but honestly i think it needs some core
ideas that i don't think we have and
it's not a money limited problem
i mean there are there are um and even
in the in the case of you know in a very
very elementary case you know we run
these
summer camps for high school students i
recommend them to to
anybody who's of the right to uh in the
right demographic who's here but but
um you know i've been interested in
in providing scholarships for those etc
etc etc
turns out it's actually hard to spend
that money in some sense because
the people for whom that would be a
wonderful match
of come to our summer camp will pay for
it etc etc etc
aren't the people who know that the
summer camp is happening
or know that that financial aid is
available and so there's a completely
different problem it has nothing to do
with money
that is you know is a sort of problem of
communication
and and sort of the the way that um
uh things are stratified stratified
unfortunately
in the world that make it difficult
to have that communication and it's not
just a question of money i mean you
could throw
you know i could say okay i'll spend x
amount of money to solve that problem i
don't know what i would do
i you know i don't know what to do to
solve that problem
with money so to speak i mean i i could
think of a few things but they're just a
complete waste of money and they would
have
a um uh you know that their their
fractional return would be just absurdly
small and it's really
like a pure waste but so so that's some
uh i mean i would say that the um uh
i had a very uh you know i've been
fortunate enough that that um
uh you know i started doing things with
companies and so on very early in my
life
and so i've been um i i've i've usually
been in the situation where
i i make more money than i then i
personally
find easy ways to spend and so i and i'm
not um and i think
i i don't pay that much attention to um
uh
you know it's not my my yeah
so i don't think it's made it's made
that much um i mean as a practical
matter
you know i have a a nice comfortable
life so to speak
um which probably helps a lot in um
in being productive in in thinking about
things and doing science and so on i
mean it's like
like they're probably things where i
have delegated them to other people and
other people do them for themselves and
i'm like
it's better it's a better calculation
for me to make some more money
and spend the money getting somebody
else to do that
than to do it myself um of course you
know
it's amazing how much stuff you know
that's again a complicated trade-off
because
there are things where you know i'm i'm
i've had lots of experience about doing
certain kinds of things and it's like
i'm pretty
pretty efficient at doing them and
there's a question of is it better
to have somebody else to delegate that
to somebody else costs some money but
if you don't worry about that money
you're delegating something to somebody
else but
the question is uh you know they may not
be as experienced as you are they may
not be as good at doing that particular
thing as you are
um what's the trade-off between what
should you delegate and what should you
just do yourself
and sometimes i end up doing things and
it's a sort of a shocking activity for a
ceo like me but i like to try to
understand what um
you know how how things in our company
work and sometimes there are problems
where it's like look i can just solve
that problem
other people will spend days weeks
trying to solve it it's going to take me
a limited time i might as well just
solve it
i'm i'm reminded particularly a few
weeks ago of a problem that was
admittedly a bit frustrating was um
uh the connectivity of our so we have a
whole cloud infrastructure system and
some part of it
lost its connection to the outside world
so that meant that some
operations that were people were doing
with the cloud just didn't work
and so the the very good team that we
have that deals with these kinds of
things was trying to solve this problem
and a few hours went by and they still
hadn't solved the problem and so i'm
like
okay look let me look at this because i
think i might be able to solve it so
i dig into this and two or three hours
later we'd solve the problem it was sort
of an interesting problem to solve it
was a
was very tricky actually it had to do
with you know packets of information
being sent
over over the internet and some packets
would arrive other ones would not arrive
there's a certain always on the internet
you know about you know one or two
percent of every
packet of information that's sent on the
internet just doesn't arrive
it's kind of a shockingly you know uh
bad system in a sense but
but the way the internet is built the um
the system the thing that
what happens is a packet is sent a
packet is some
uh then there's a receipt sent back if
the packet arrives
if there's some if there's no receipt
that's received the packet is resent
and um that's the tcp protocol um
the um in um uh
and in any case in this particular case
some packets
were just many more than two percent of
packets
of certain kinds of packets were just
disappearing
and and i figured out i mean it was just
a question of doing a bit of data
analysis of looking at here a whole
bunch of packets
what happens to different packets oh
these packets that are going to this
particular
uh you know going on this particular
fiber backbone
of um to this particular internet
backbone provider
and not being delivered properly uh but
the other one that ones to another
provider are being delivered et cetera
et cetera et cetera
and end result okay here's the problem
and then we go and fix it
and you know i i at some level it's like
it's a bit frustrating to be like gosh
we've got you know many layers of very
capable people
and um uh you know why am i delegating
this problem to be solved but the fact
was
you know in the end i don't know how
long it would have taken to solve this
problem it might have taken a week to
solve this problem
um and uh you know i think that sort of
some additional experience plus in that
particular case
some facility with tools particularly
our language tools
for exploring these kinds of things was
super useful in debugging what was going
on
and anyway it felt like a at least type
it it was a sign of um
it's a little bit of non-helplessness so
to speak in the sense that
yes i can actually go and debug this
kind of thing myself if i really need to
all right
um
there's a question from a user
temporarily suspended okay it's an
interesting
uh handle if you've got a chance to talk
to richard feynman right now in 2020
and ask only one question what would it
be
you know i asked a lot of questions to
dick fineman while he was alive
um i think
let me see the question is did i learn
enough from him
that i think i could sort of predict his
response to any question
or other questions where i uh
wouldn't know his response and really
would want to ask it
i think that um
i mean there are historical questions of
curiosity that i have
but i don't think those rise to such a
level of importance
i think that um uh i would have to yakk
on for a while
telling him about what we figured out in
our physics project and so on
and um uh i think he'd be very
um very excited about that
i think there are many things that we've
managed to resolve
that he wondered about for a long long
long time and i think that um
uh his you know he took computers very
seriously
um and thought that computation was an
important kind of thing to think about
but sort of the connections that we
managed to find to physics i think
would be um i would not entirely
surprise him
but he would find very satisfying and
for example one particular question
about uh well i think the the path
integral of quantum mechanics that he
invented
we've kind of figured out sort of how
that works and how it relates to
einstein's equations and
in general activity and so on i think he
would find that i
i can kind of kind of remembering him i
can kind of
think of actual words he would use to
express his excitement
for that connection because i think he
would find that connection really really
quite amazing and um i know what he
would ask me
he would ask me did you solve the
problem of why
e to the t y it's e to the i h t and e
to the minus beta h
so the the e to the iht is a formula in
quantum mechanics that represents the
time evolution
of a system in quantum mechanics and e
to the minus beta h
is a formula that represents the um
statistical probabilities
in thermodynamics and statistical
mechanics and i talked to him for ages
and ages about why are they both
exponentials of the same form
with the same dependence on the energy
function and so on and he's like there's
got to be a way to do this there's got
to be a way to understand why this is
why this works this way it's not a
coincidence et cetera et cetera et
cetera i think we now know how that
works
um i think another thing that he always
used to ask
is one of the techniques he invented
these things called fimin diagrams
so uh finite diagrams if you're looking
at for example an electron
uh the scattering of one electron by
another so you
shoot two electrons at each other and
they have an electric charge
and they also have at a quantum quantum
mechanical level
they uh you think of them as exchanging
virtual photons
and so there's all these processes where
the things will scatter
because they one of them generated a
virtual photon and that hit the other
one and that pushed the other one and so
on
and there are all these sort of separate
processes they can exchange not one
virtual photon but two virtual photons
or a virtual photon that turns into a
virtual electron positron pair
turns back into a virtual photon there
are all these different ways
microscopically that that scattering
process can happen
and one of the things dick feynman did
was to invent this method called fimin
diagrams
which was a way to compute the
probabilities
of all those different uh little sort of
ways that scattering can happen and so
one of the things is that if you want to
get a rough estimate of what the
scattering probability is
you can just consider a few processes in
a few diagrams if you want to get it
more accurate
you start having to consider thousands
of diagrams tens of thousands millions
of diagrams and so on
and um one of the things that and each
one of those diagrams is a huge amount
of computer effort
to uh uh to compute what the probability
implied by that diagram it's a very
nice interesting kind of computational
thing to do but it's very complicated
and and so dick feinman even though he
invented this method always used to say
it's the stupidest method you know the
fact you have to go to so much effort
to work these things out it's just crazy
and by the way
you might have a thousand diagrams with
all kinds of detailed complicated
integrals and all this kind of thing
and the answer is 17 pi squared over 6
or something
all these different pieces all add
together and eventually get a simple
answer
and that should be kind of a clue that
all these diagrams weren't necessary
that there was a simpler way to get to
that answer
but nobody's ever found it there's some
hopes from
some mathematical methods that come out
of string theory that there might be a
a a way to um
to sort of have a simpler way to deduce
what
the um uh what the results from these
finite diagram calculations are but that
hasn't yet worked out
um but that's uh that's one of the
things that was one of the kind of
the unfinished pieces of business from
from dick feynman was
these firemen diagram things that he
invented he's like these are really
stupid there's got to be a better way to
do this
um but we don't know it yet and and the
methods that we've
invented um don't directly give us any
particular insight that i can
that i know of actually quite sure i
haven't really thought about that
good question there's the the buzz word
for
a bunch of the sort of new approach to
these things is the thing called the
ample pseudohedron
um and um i think we've had some
thoughts about how the amplitude of
heater and relates to some of the things
that we are
looking at in our models but this would
get that would get um
highly highly technical to talk about
well
now let me not try the um
uh anyway so so the answer is i don't
have a really good answer to your
question i'm afraid
um okay there's a question from saul
here
is it easy to make a bot for every video
game
and how good can anti-bot detection
methods be
well first an admission from me i really
have never played video games
i i kind of wrote a little tiny computer
game back in like 1973 that was
incredibly trivial
and i never found it that interesting
and i haven't really played video games
since i'm my
awareness of that world comes from
building some tools that get used there
and from knowing a lot of people who are
involved in that world
so i'm i'm less up on exactly what
happens in video games these days than i
probably should be
it's a blind spot of mine um but
uh the real question is if you've got
an entity in a video game and it's
pretending that it's a human at the
other end of the
line so to speak can you tell well first
of all can you build something which
will emulate human level performance
in the game and second of all
if you've got this player in the game
can you tell if that player
has an actual human underneath it or did
it merely have a human programmer and
it's a bot
does it have a human sort of puppeting
it in real time or
is it something where you know there's
no human still in the loop
so i i don't really know the answer
to um whether uh
you know to what extent it's possible to
make a
bot that successfully achieves sort of
human level play in video games
you know it's been a it's been a long
running question if we look at different
kinds of games whether it's chess
or go or backgammon or whatever else
at what point can we make a um
a computer that will achieve sort of
human levels of play
and in those games the main issue is
there are lots of possible things that
can happen in the game can you kind of
figure out what all the possibilities
for what could happen are
can you see six moves in the in the
future what all the millions and
millions of possibilities are
and say look the chances are if i make
this move
that will lead to the best outcome six
moves from now and that's kind of been
the main approach that's been used in
kind of getting
sort of human level uh play in in these
non-video you know games like chess and
so on um
i i think that the in a sense there's a
question of how
human or non-human is that process in
other words when human chess players
are doing their thing to what extent are
they in their minds
sort of working out all these
possibilities and to what extent are
they using quite different heuristics
quite different ways of guessing
what should be done and quite different
kinds of intuition that they can't
necessarily explain
about what to do but you know the
computer way
is very much sort of let's just see what
could possibly happen
and then pick the move that will with
best
probability give me a good outcome six
moves in the future
okay so to what extent can that be done
in video games i do not know
um i'm i'm i think that um actually now
that i think about it
yeah we even you know we've done
experiments with machine learning
on simple video games like sort of 8-bit
video games from the you know from the
ancient you know 1980s or something
and i think that there are methods
uh so-called reinforcement learning
methods that do
okay at playing those games in fact now
they think about it i was at the
demo sort of the first public demo given
of a very
sort of a supposedly very impressive ai
system that was playing
video games and actually i somehow was a
medium-sized group and somehow the the
person organizing it
you know somebody gave this this grand
demo this was a
company called deepmind that was sort of
the first public demo of these things
and so
the organizer of this thing kind of
shows this demo and then after the demo
kind of happens to turn to me and say
okay was that impressive or not
and i'm like well i don't really know
because i just don't know how hard it is
to play that game
and um uh you know it's um
and that's a common issue is um i
remember many years ago a person who
um uh worked in the group by iran um
uh did that did because it did the first
sort of neural network approach
to playing backgammon um and it was like
i'm looking at these things he's doing
and it's like i have no idea how
you know is this impressive this is not
impressive i have no idea because i
don't know how hard
this i don't really know how hard this
problem is so
um in any case the the um you know a
certain amount of success has
has been achieved using very
straightforward reinforcement learning
techniques what is reinforcement
learning
basically the idea is uh in in general
what you're doing in
in machine learning is you give a bunch
of examples
and then you say to the machine okay
you've seen these examples
now i'm going to show you a new thing
what is the example
uh okay with a bunch of examples you say
this is an example of pictures of dogs
as an example of pictures of cats
now you show the machine a picture and
you say based on those examples you saw
is it a cat or a dog
and so the machine has to kind of
statistically work out
based on all the examples it saw what's
the likelihood is it a cat or a dog
okay so reinforcement learning the idea
is that um you kind of the machine is
sort of probing the world
to find out what would happen if this
you know if you did this what happens in
other words rather than you
surfacing whether you're just giving it
here a bunch of examples
now learn from those it's like the
machine is generating its own examples
by saying well if i move like this
what will happen if i if my opponent you
know if i do this what will my opponent
do et cetera et cetera et cetera
and so that's a that's a sort of a
pattern uh for doing machine learning
and um i think one can achieve a certain
degree of success
i don't think it's like slam dunk
amazing
and i think with more complex video
games it probably gets much more more
difficult
and my guess is that the sort of treeing
out of possibilities
for something like chess there's only a
discreet set of possible places where
you can put pieces on the board
in a video game you can move that that
um mario character or something it's
about my level of
video game um knowledge um
you know to a particular place and you
know which pixel do you get to
what else was happening in the game
there it's not a finite
situation in the same way a discrete
situation in the same way that it is
with something like chess
it's much harder to sort of tree out all
the possibilities
so my guess is not that easy to build a
bot that does a really good job
of um of navigating uh a typical
modern complex video game and i think
that's
that's kind of a uh you know in um
in fact now they think about it i've
seen a bunch of demos of these kinds of
things and none of them have been all
that impressive
so uh you know and i think the extent to
which
you need to do you know that it's
difficult to do that is also the extent
to which if you said well
i just want a bot that's going to answer
my email for me
well you know insofar as video games are
a good model of the world
it's sort of the same problem to play a
video game well it's like can you
actually navigate things that are sort
of like the real world
and that's difficult because it depends
on a lot of things that are kind of
built in cultural knowledge of humans
that go back a long way and so on
and are not easy to to sort of expect to
encode
in a kind of one shot i'm just built to
play a video game kind of device
if you're kind of emulating everything
the human does it's different story but
i doubt that it's something that's
possible
based on kind of just the pure i'm going
to build this thing to play a video game
and that's it
so question of whether you can tell
whether something is a bot or a human
um that's an interesting and challenging
thing there's a there's a general
question of
can you tell if something was an
artifact or something as a
as a as a as a thing that was just made
by nature can you tell if something was
done on purpose
can you tell if something was done as a
program as opposed to by a person
um i think that's you know that's the
story you know you go to your average
website
and you try and do one of those captures
so you know it's like
well there are these letters and they're
distorted in this way can you read what
these letters say
you know is that something a human can
do i often find those things pretty
difficult to decode
um you know what on earth is this letter
and i don't even know whether they care
about
actually i should learn this once and
for all whether these things care about
capital
or lowercase um the distinction between
those things but anyway
you know it's sometimes really hard you
see an x i don't know if that's supposed
to be a capital x or lowercase x no idea
i don't know whether it cares what i
type in but anyway so so that's a case
where you're trying to have something
which is
doable by human but not doable by
machine and similarly these things
saying you know
find all the bicycles in this picture or
something are again
things which are kind of sort of doable
by humans but but not by machines except
those are increasingly doable by machine
and my guess is that the most of those
things so
so if you if you define a specific task
like that
it's um it's probably the case that you
can make a machine
uh you know successfully train it to do
that particular task
um you know this is a the general
question of are you a bot or a human
uh you know a common version of this is
is this idea of alan turing's from 1950
the turing test where kind of the
question is
if you uh sat down at a computer and uh
well he didn't think of it that way
because he didn't know about computers
that way but he just says
you're asking questions to a thing and
the question is is the thing a human
or is the thing a computer and the issue
is what questions do you ask
to tell whether it's a a human or or a
computer
and um you know so so people have tried
to make
sort of conversation bots that try to
fool people about thinking that oh no
it's really a
human not just a bot um
it hasn't worked very well but somehow
if you say what's a systematic method of
testing
it's actually fairly hard to come up
with a systematic method of testing
because in a sense that systematic test
has to itself be as good as the bot
that you are trying to produce so to
speak so
one giveaway there are a bunch of these
bots which use wolfen alpha as their
source of computational knowledge
about the world and so one absolute
giveaway is you just ask these bizarre
different questions about
different things in the world if it can
answer all of those it's not a human
no human can do that no human knows
these different diverse
things with precision um in the way that
you know you can just look them up and
wear from alpha
so so that's kind of a weird way to to
conclude that because you might think oh
the human will be much more
capable than any computer but but not in
that way at least
um and so so it's a really interesting
question you know if you
uh people at different times have have
put up these various chat bots
i have to say that the you know very
early chatbot was this thing called
eliza that was done even in the 1960s
and it was a was kind of an imitation of
a of a sort of psychologist talking to a
person
and you know the bot would say um
i don't know would say something um you
make a statement
i i like the color orange
no that would be a bad statement to make
it something like um
uh uh i ate an
apple at lunchtime today and it would
then say
how do you feel about eating an apple at
lunch time
and you know there's a sort of question
of how how realistically sort of human
does that end up being
something that's interesting about that
is it's it's pretty
non-convincing pretty quickly but one
thing is sort of interesting is that
even though it's somehow non-convincing
it doesn't mean
that we don't respond to it in some way
as
sort of humans with emotional responses
i mean it's just like
i don't know there are situations in
which we are
you know um in which
we're confronted with something that is
not
the real thing with its whole story but
is sort of an
imitation that still makes us feel i
mean i don't know we have
um oh what's a good example a bad
example
would be something like you know plastic
wood you know you you can have something
where well you think you know it's a
wooden surface that's all very nice it
has some particular meaning but oh no
you have a plastic you know
wood that plast you know just plastic
that that is you know
wood textured so to speak well that's
kind of
you know we still feel might feel pretty
good about that in certain situations
um even though it doesn't really have
the whole story behind
it's the fine wooden surface so to speak
um
and i think that it's the same kind of
thing that happens with these chat bots
that even though we kind of know that
it's not a real thing
it kind of elicits certain kinds of
responses in us
that are sort of real to us even though
we know the thing that's soliciting them
is not um uh well you know here's a good
example actually something a little bit
like that you know
um uh if you have you know a fire alarm
or a siren or something like this
those sounds sort of plug into
probably very basic circuits in our
brains that are like
no that was a you know something crying
out in some person crying out in some
way
it captures some essence of those sounds
and so we pay attention to it and we
respond emotionally to it even though we
perfectly well know
that's just you know an alarm system or
something
um and uh uh you know so i think the
same is true to some extent with chat
bots even though
they don't really achieve the full sort
of human level you know you could really
not
tell that isn't a human it's still
something which we respond to in some
in some kind of way but i think it's an
interesting question with a sort of a
systematic way to tell
whether the turing test is being passed
well but that sort of requires having
passed the turing test and i think it's
kind of a
it's like saying how do we verify that
this program is doing what we want it to
do oh we need to have written another
program
that says what we wanted to do well but
we just wrote a program that tells it
what we wanted to do so it doesn't
really
doesn't really get you anywhere um
okay many many questions here and i
should
oh i'm almost out of time completely out
of time
um
let's see
a detailed comment from i see here
saying that um
be nice to have a zip file of all
notebooks from the wolfram physics
project technical introduction that's a
good suggestion
hopefully somebody in my team can note
that down
um
let's see
um
there's a question okay i'll take do one
more here there's a bunch of physics
questions which are perfectly
interesting but
um uh
i can't can't cover all of these today
um
um a question from and i'll i'll save
them up for next time
question from fabry um
it's a question about outreach to
students
and helping people succeed and
increasing
outreach that um one does to students
you know as i was sort of explaining
before the challenge is
reaching the right people i mean even
you know
this live stream uh you know
i have no idea whether we're reaching
the people
all the people i'm sure we're not
reaching all the people and students and
so on
who might find this interesting uh you
know
it's i'd love to get ideas about how to
reach those people
um it's uh uh
it can be awfully challenging because
people
um i mean it's so
uh there's sort of so much uh there's a
great extent to which people sort of
don't understand
people particularly young people you
know how do they know what's out there
in the world to do
unless somebody tells them it's really
hard for them to know now you might say
well let's just find it on the web well
yes at least in these days that's
possible
but still you have to kind of have the
idea that there might be something like
that out there i mean there are plenty
of times
where i realize i don't know i've been
doing historical research recently
about a particular topic i can talk
about another time um
that um uh where you know i'm
continually like
really are there actually scans of phone
books from moscow in the 1930s
well maybe there are but i sort of just
didn't know that was out there but i
know enough to know to look to see
whether it's out there
as opposed to just i couldn't possibly
know
whether there was somebody in a moscow
phone book in the 1930s so to speak
um so i think that there's sort of a
challenge of
of you know even if one provides a bunch
of resources
how does one actually uh how do the
people who are
relevant to take advantage of those
research
resources get access to them and from my
point of view as i say we have
our um summer camp for high school
students
actually just yesterday was was uh
thinking about that
in connection with with the fact that we
have just a terrific group of students
who come
every year i mean different ones every
year but but um
uh but in a sense our criteria for these
students
uh probably exclude some students for
whom it really would be a good thing but
they're not nearly as prepared as the
other students
and this is sort of a common problem in
educational settings that
you know there might be students where
it would really be you know an important
and worthwhile thing for that student
to be pulled into this educational
setting but they're not really quite
ready for it
and they need to do some other stuff
first but then you've got a whole bunch
of other people who are ready
you don't want to kind of hold those
people back and so on so you have to
kind of invent some kind of segmented
approach and i'm trying to think about
how to do that
um and uh that deals with kind of having
a way for
to have people who are much better
prepared
and can just jump right into sort of
one program of education and then people
who are less well prepared
and who can jump into another one and
sometimes there's a challenge because
not only do people not
know content they also sort of just
don't have the idea
that you know of doing projects of of
sort of
learning things in a particular way i
don't know how to learn stuff
i don't know how to do a project um
those kinds of things
uh which are sort of different problems
personally i find those
uh you know i i i find those i think
very valuable things to communicate
but they usually have to be communicated
experientially like
the i don't know how to do a project so
i'll tell you something about doing
projects so
so you know for whatever reason when i
was pretty young i got
into this kind of perhaps egotistical
point of view that i'm much more
interested in doing projects that
nobody's ever done before
than in doing exercises that lots of
people have already done
okay maybe it's a piece of personal sort
of egotism
that i want to do something special but
that was
you know a point of view that i had from
very early on and
and then it was like well what problems
you know should i try to solve that
people haven't solved before or whatever
what projects should i try to do and
it's like well i mean i
just started well this is interesting
let me go try and figure this out
i don't think i have to my great
surprise because i just sort of thought
everybody always does that
i don't think it's so common people just
think oh if it hasn't been done before
it must be impossible
that's not my point of view my point of
view tends to be
if it hasn't been done before well
nobody got around to doing it
it doesn't mean it's necessarily uh
certainly doesn't mean it's impossible
doesn't even necessarily mean it's
terribly hard
it just means for whatever reason people
were pointed in some direction
nobody got around to doing it it hasn't
been done
so you know but i think this idea that
you can just
invent something and then just sort of
turn it into something that becomes real
in the world is
not something that people are as
familiar with seeing and particularly
not kids
i mean i've noticed that um you know one
of the things that
that it's always uh you know if you name
products after yourself like wolfman
alpha for example
um that has all kinds of very bizarre
consequences that
some of them are kind of fun some of
them are a little annoying but but um
uh one of the ones that i find
particularly charming is this
you know i'll go and i'll give some talk
to some group of students somewhere
and uh they know my name and
uh what and it's kind of like oh um
they suddenly realized to ask oh are you
something to do with that wolfman alpha
thing
and it's like well yes you know yes that
that's my thing so to speak
um and uh and they're like oh
that's interesting and you can kind of
for me it's like
wheels are turning not that oh there's
this
there's this guy into this thing who
cares it's rather
this general notion that that
you know behind this thing that people
use on the web and it just sort of
exists out there
is an actual person who decided to do it
and decided to build this thing and went
from nothing
to to uh to actually a thing that was
built that people
use out there in the world and i think
this notion that one can go from nothing
to something
and that that's a thing people can do is
something that
is unfortunately a minority of people
particularly kids
really understand that point and it's a
very empowering point to understand
that you know everything was you know
that we have and software whatever else
ideas they were invented by somebody and
you know it's not like it's off even for
myself i i
you know any field that i don't know
about i at first kind of think oh
they invented this someone some out
there in the in the
in the kind of distant mists of whatever
they invented this and then as i study
history of science and things like that
it's like
oh this person with this whole history
invented this because of this and this
and this
and they were in the right place and
knew the right things to to invent this
and it all feels a lot more uh
personally doable so to speak after you
know
uh sort of that chain of of things that
happened and so on and i think that's a
uh that that's a piece to sort of uh
empowering people to understand that
point
and i as a sort of hobby i've i've done
a certain amount of i
i do two kinds of mentoring uh ceos and
kids
and they have a a charming similarity
actually
i mean you know uh which is that they
both
at least the ones i i find interesting
they both
have the feature that they take the
point of view that anything is possible
some ceo of some you know company is
like well
yeah we can do that let's you know go
and build this piece out to the company
and you know
i'll get you know et cetera et cetera et
cetera and similarly kids you know at an
early stage in life it's like
yes it's possible that i can do this and
become that
and so on and so on and so on and those
things are kind of fun and i've um
i find it for me personally i find it
really quite interesting
and it is very charming to the extent to
which the issues
between kids particularly kids in in
slightly complicated circumstances
and ceos are the same and you know
they're always it's
a lot of internal issues in a sense of
do i really have the nerve to do that
you know
do i really have um you know do i really
you know have um i have the enthusiasm
the energy the initiative to do that
and so on or you know or sometimes
uh you know that's really not a good
idea you know you think it's a good idea
because you've you've
you've got in your mind you've got this
whole set of things that you're
imagining
but those things are not realistic in
the world and it's just not
you know that that isn't a good way to
do it and you know
pick a different direction but um in any
case
the um uh i'm just
seeing a few comments here um
oh boy there's a question about central
banks that's an interesting question
um oh lots of people commenting they
came from lex friedman's podcast good
for lex
he's a great interviewer i i'm you know
i've done lots of interviews with lots
of people
and some of them i feel like uh i'm
saying really interesting things and
others i'm like if i was listening to
this i would be falling asleep but lex
he's really good at um at uh
uh getting sort of the best stuff
out of um out of people inclu including
perhaps me
um let's see there's comments here let
me just cover these and then i should
get going
um let's see it's comments from february
here about
uh partnering with educators on youtube
to produce content that's interesting
that could show people um
yeah well this is a comment about about
showing people that
uh just because you don't know how to do
your math exercises really well doesn't
mean you can't
do can't make great contributions to
stem kinds of subjects
yeah i mean look i'm i'm a um sort of an
example of that when i was a kid
age nine ten years old or something i
was like
uh i don't like math i'm not very good
at it
uh you know other people get much better
marks in their
you know grades in that in the exercises
than i do i'm pretty crummy at math
but i was really interested in physics
and so i kind of like i've got to solve
this math problem
and so then a little while later i
realized actually
there's a way to do this use computers
to do it so i don't have to do the parts
of the math that i find
boring and not terribly good at and um
so you know it's one of these
look there is a solution so to speak um
and uh
and you can get to it but but i think as
a practical matter you know
i hope that for example these live
streams and i'm i'd be certainly very
interested in people's suggestions about
um uh i think we're chopping up these
live streams into
into podcasts about particular topics i
mean as you
as you realize these live streams are
are 100 off the cuff
um and uh and so i'm um
but i think um and they're not sort of
organized to be about particular topics
but i think we're chopping them up
into particular topics and hopefully
they will provide some content
that um um is useful to people in sort
of understanding
uh sort of stem kinds of things uh and
um i hope
with decent explanation i mean i should
i should say that
uh you know the things i talk about here
for what it's worth
some fraction of them you could sort of
find if you read a bunch of textbooks
some fraction i know perfectly well that
these are completely not well known and
not well understood things
that i happen to for one reason or
another because i've actually studied
the science of it myself or because i
know people
involved in that area or whatever i
happen to know and one of the things
that i suppose is
as i don't know that's good strategy or
bad strategy but
um i don't really make a distinction
between those things i'm just sort of
saying things like
you know people know xyz uh you know
it's
like i know that because i know the
person
who is the leader in that field who
figured that out last year so to speak
i don't really make a distinction
between that and i learned that
50 years ago from some textbook type
thing
um and uh you know i suppose that that
um so so you know that's kind of my um
uh i mean you know i don't think it
really matters if
if the goal is to understand doesn't
really matter whether i learned that as
a very special thing that only i know
or that that's something that's fairly
well known that's kind of a different
issue
um but uh you know what what i'm trying
to do is to explain things
and and i have to tell you that that um
uh
uh for whatever good it may do for other
people
these um these live streams have been
great for me because i am really
sure that i have become a better
explainer of things through spending
this time
explaining stuff to on these live
streams and i noticed we just had our
annual technology conference and i
always do q and a's and things at annual
technology conference
and that that's based a year apart and i
realized
i am better at doing these q as than i
was a year ago
and the reason is because i've been
doing these live streams so that's a
thank you to
to people who've been participating in
these um
i'm just going to look at one more
comment here about reaching people
um
okay there's a specific list of um
uh of science youtube channels i
i know a few of the people involved in
these not others great
hopefully that the team can can write
down this list and um
uh and and um take that suggestion
um
okay good there's some there's some
great um
uh great questions saved up for next
week
so uh please
tune in again what's the right word for
a live stream it's not tune in
tune in is adjust the variable capacitor
on your transistor radio
or something i don't know what the right
term is uh connect
again next next week look forward to uh
to hearing from you all
um but uh uh thanks for being here
bye for now oh i'm being told join us as
the right um right terminology
okay all right so um
bye for now please please join us again
next next week